bassem bonjour alors les propriétaires
de cafés bars et restaurants se
préparent à cette réouverture nîmes est
effectivement lives il se prépare après
l annonce du président de la république
doré ouverture progressivement des bars
des restaurants et de lieux culturels à
partir de mi-mai ça a été confirmée par
le porte parole du gouvernement et
gabriela talent une phase de ré
ouverture qui se fera bien sûr
progressivement en respectant un
calendrier et puis surtout en respectant
certaines conditions mais c'est une
lueur d'espoir quand même pour les
restaurateurs sur l'ensemble du
territoire nous sommes ici dans un
restaurant du 4e arrondissement de paris
je suis avec romain vidal le directeur
de cet établissement alors expliqué une
lueur d'espoir pour vous cette
réouverture
oui bonjour oui bien sûr une lueur
d'espoir car on avait besoin de
travailler de savoir comment déjà
s'organiser pour travailler ouvrez une
brasserie ou un restaurant ou un bar ça
se fait pas d'un claquement de doigts en
24 heures tout comme le fermer
d'ailleurs il nous faut prévenir nos
salariés prévenir nos fournisseurs faire
le ménage pour mettre en route les
machines c'est du travail c'est du temps
donc on a besoin d'avoir déjà ce délai
pour pouvoir travailler à la mise en
place et ensuite bien sûr pouvoir ouvrir
pour pouvoir commencer à rembourser les
dettes qu'on a cumulé avec le pg e et
tout l'est d'ailleurs tout les mois de
fermeture qu'on avait passé en arrière
aujourd'hui à quelques semaines de cette
réouverture vous êtes plutôt serein où
il demeure quand même des inquiétudes
il restera toujours des inquiétudes là
on attend toujours des détails
techniques qui sont en négociation avec
les organisations professionnelles
on sait que normalement de rouvrir mi
mai que les terrasses on sait qu'il va y
avoir le protocole sanitaire
on espère que ce soit le même parce
qu'il est déjà très coté niant et en
plus il a fait ses preuves
la question c'est de savoir comment on
va être accompagné pour cette
réouverture parce qu'on va travailler
qu'avec une partie donc notre
établissement les terrasses avec un
protocole sanitaire chez moi c'est 40%
de moins de ma terrasse et la terrasse
représente déjà 30% de monde surface
devant l'établissement faut qu'on puisse
avoir une ouverture qui sont rentables
car déjà quand on était fermé pour
certains en 2020 quand on était ferme et
légale est passé d' aide s'était pas
rentable d'être fermé là si on est
ouvert axé pas rentable ça va pas
pouvoir continuer il faut à falloir
qu'on bien sûr qu'on reprenne nos
activités avec nos salariés beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur l'accompagnement sur
le retour des parisiens nous on est à
paris
c'est très compliqué parce que juillet
août tournoi personne on le sait déjà
donc il faut qu'on ouvre vite pour
pouvoir avoir au moins quelques semaines
de travail devant nous parce qu'en
juillet août la question se posera
d'être ouvert ou fermé son pari il était
temps pour vous cette réouverture vous
êtes arrivé à vivre notamment avec les
aides du gouvernement où vous auriez pu
rester encore plus longtemps fermé où sa
tombe à pic cette réouverture
alors les aides jusqu'au mois de
novembre ne suffisait pas pour un
établissement comme nous comme
d'ailleurs pour tous les établissements
avec 1500 euros pour nous
personnellement ça nous payer l expert
comptable c'est tout ce que ça pouvait
payer donc ça ne suffisait largement pas
du tout heureusement il ya des activités
partielles pour nos salariés mais un
établissement à des charges fixes et
bien sûr le paillage leur venue du
patron en général et donc ça ne
suffisait pas à partir de la fin de
l'année on a eu les 20% de fond de
sonorités qui sont qui ont permis de
payer déjà une partie chercher fixe donc
c'est plus important c'est sûr mais ça
ne suffit pas toujours parce qu'on a
quand même des charges fixant des
charges variables et on a besoin de
faire tourner la machine
donc on a nous on a réattaqué depuis
janvier la réouverture parce qu'on a vu
qu'on n'ouvrait pas de qu'on n'était pas
prêts d'ouvrir donc on a réattaqué avec
une vente à emporter qui représente 10 %
notre chiffre d'affaires d'habituel mais
ça permet d'entretenir déjà la main
d'oeuvre les gestes techniques du chef
il les a retrouvés on a redémarré la
cuisine c'était aussi important et
surtout reprendre contact avec les gens
du quartier et pas avoir un espace clos
en plein coeur de paris ce serait
dommage
merci beaucoup romain alors vous l'aurez
compris olivier une lueur d'espoir pour
tous et restaurateurs mais les détails
que doit annoncer encore le gouvernement
leur permettra de préparer cette
réouverture des ouvertures qui se fera
progressivement à commencer par les
terrasses qui sera pendant la phase 1
annoncées par le gouvernement pour
pouvoir progressivement ouvrir en salle
certains restaurants malheureusement qui
ne bénéficient pas de terrasse ne
pourront pas rouvrir pendant cette
première phase
les autres on est déjà à l'heure de la
préparation de cette fameuse à
l'ouverture après plus de huit mois de
fermeture
en tout cas c'est mon on a atteint 2 de
soutenir ses restaurants une petite
faveur si vous pouviez me commander un
double expresso c'est possible bah c'est
possible on voit tout de suite
merci beaucoup en tout cas bassène pour
ces précisions bassam suivi en direct du
4e arrondissement de paris